[Music]
this is star talk neil degrasse tyson
here your personal astrophysicist i got
chuck nice with me jack hey neil
how's it going chuck one of your
favorite subjects today how to save
ourselves
from a climate crisis that's right and
because no one else is going to save us
we got to save ourselves and
it ain't going to be the aliens
no no one's showing up
not yet all right and so you who we have
for this we got catherine hayo and she's
not her first time on star talk
catherine welcome back
thank you so much it's great to be with
you here again and you know i would love
to be people's personal climate
scientists is that title available i i
don't see why not yeah go ahead and do
that but then you got to be like respond
when they call you see that's what i'm
saying yeah and it's just just it comes
with some some obligations right right
so i already do that i already do that
on twitter i respond to a lot of people
there okay
so we're going to do a cosmic queries
out of this but there's so much other
information we want to get from you
that the cosmic aquarius will be on the
outskirts of what we try to do here with
you so let me remind people you're an
atmospheric scientist right
and your professor of political science
let me get here director of climate
science center
at texas tech all right so there you go
and you're
recently
chief scientist at the nature
conservancy did i say that right the
nature conservancy so
i want to find out from you in a minute
how that happened but uh more
importantly right now your author of
saving us
just came out in
2021 so i want to find out all about all
of that
so kevin how did you land at the nature
conservancy
well the nature conservancy many people
have probably heard of because they're
the biggest global conservation
organization in the world they work in
76 countries around the world and
they've got chapters in every state and
you might have taken a walk or a hike on
one of their preserves in the past
but like so many other organizations
they're recognizing that if we don't fix
climate change
we can't fix anything else
and so now the nature conservancy has
climate change and biodiversity right at
the very top of its global priorities
because they know that climate change is
a threat multiplier and that is what
stands between us and a better future
man using using military
threat multiplier
threat
it's like whoa i guess it is it's a
battle it says it's a battle for our
lives at the end of all this
so
yes we're with you on this so kevin if
we're supposed to do something about it
why why isn't it the industry's fault
all right collective industries they
seem to be the biggest climate polluters
out there so
so what what's up with that
well it really is industries followed i
mean 90 corporations are responsible for
two-thirds of heat trapping gas
emissions since the dawn of the
industrial era
we need a system-wide solution
but systems are made up of people
even corporations are made up of people
my friend don't you know that my friend
corporations are people my friend
that was not what i said
and you're absolutely there is a big
difference
okay
but that was my mitt romney thank you
okay so so a corporation
uh
rather than thinking of them as a as a
as a monolith we think of them as
comprised of people who have the same
interest as we do
most of them do
there's always a few people who will put
short-term profit over the long-term
welfare of themselves their children
their grandchildren and the future of
the human race as we know it damn how to
make a corporate guy feel bad
[Laughter]
that sounded like
a lady i'm just trying to make a buck
okay
well you know what you kneel you
actually hit it on the head we've
incentivized the people who run
corporations to be extremely
short-sighted because their their reward
is in upping the stock price which means
at all costs they'll do whatever
they need catherine we created the rules
that that sandbox that they're playing
in and now we're gonna now we're gonna
complain that they're
doing what the sandbox was intended to
do
well that's exactly it that's why we
need system-wide change it isn't enough
to just change one thing over here one
thing over there and it definitely isn't
enough to just focus on our personal
carbon footprint right i mean when we
talk about climate action most people
immediately go to light bulbs and
recycling or diet and plug-in cars and
solar panels and you know don't get me
wrong i've done all of those things but
i've done the math and even if all of us
who are worried did everything we could
to reduce our personal footprint that
wouldn't even be twenty percent of the
problem but then people say oh the
solution
the solution yes
it wouldn't even tackle 20 of the
problem so then people say okay so that
means i can't do anything right
and my answer is no you can do something
in fact individual action is really the
only way we have seen our industrialized
society change in the past
but how we did it was not through
personal action it was through using our
voices to advocate for change yeah yeah
and and part of that is um
uh what neil said about these guys that
we created the sandbox and now they're
using it
like for kitty litter and so
you're pooping in the sandbox
you can't poop in the sandbox man
we all play in the sand box in the
sandbox right come on man like no but
when the turd gets hard then it's just
another hard thing in the in the sandbox
right right yeah well yes by then we'll
all be dead
all right wait wait so wait katherine
kevin
in my experience i agree with you but i
i i tend to have a more sort of
realistic view and that is i've only
ever seen
everyone change
not all the time but most of the time
when people change
even when there were sort of
conservationists and people uh tooting
that horn they only end up changing when
the act of changing improves their
wallet
and
or
so consider you know the movement to
stop killing the whales you know back in
the 1800s and then we stopped killing
whales was it because the movement
succeeded no because we found oil right
in the ground and so economically that
whole thing switched
so don't we need an economic solution
here so that the same sandbox can now
make money
cleaning things up rather than getting
things dirty
well yes and we already do solar energy
is now the cheapest form of electricity
we have ever had in the history of human
civilization on this planet
and solar with storage because of course
the sun doesn't always shine at night um
doesn't shine at all at night in fact i
was gonna i'm glad you caught that
because i was gonna be all up in your
face on that one oh well if you're up in
the arctic no you know we can get into
those
but
that is actually cheaper than natural
gas already in many parts of the world
and right now i mean just look at the
price of gas in the united states in
many parts of the world it is a lot
cheaper to have an electric vehicle over
a pretty relatively short time frame so
the economic argument is already there
even
in a market that is heavily skewed
towards fossil fuels
the the imf the international monetary
fund not the imf that tom cruise works
for in mission impossible but the other
one the real one they estimate that
fossils but they're both real don't
don't denigrate that movie that's a
impossible mission for us
don't don't don't bad-mouth that okay go
on
well if they could just fix climate
change for us i would happily call them
real
it is an impossible mission for us i
don't know if we should give it to them
if it involves fake faces they could
definitely fix the fake faces that's a
fake face show that's right yes
but anyways the the imf says that the
united states currently
subsidizes fossil fuel use to the tune
of over 600 billion dollars which
exceeds the pentagon's budget so if you
want to follow the money we are not on a
level playing field fossil fuels are
subsidized and that is why solutions
like carbon pricing which are endorsed
by pretty much every economist in the
world including the two who won the
nobel prize a few years ago that's why
carbon pricing is one of the suite of
solutions a policy solution that we need
in tandem with our clean energy
solutions we need it to work with our
good old-fashioned efficiency solutions
because efficiency could cut our carbon
emissions in half and save us money and
our nature-based solutions where we take
carbon out of the atmosphere where we
have too much and we put it back into
the soil coastal wetlands grasslands
ecosystems trees where we want the
carbon
put all those solutions together and
then you have a plan to fix climate
change but you know to neil's point
about the
um
economics uh there's a different type of
economics attached to this issue
and it's social capital it's the idea
that people buy in you know that's and
and that means that they have to first
believe
second believe that action is necessary
with some type of urgency and then third
punish those
who will not participate in being the
solution so it's like smoking
okay at one point smoking was everywhere
it was cool they smoked on airplanes i
can't believe it when i see that they
used to smoke on airplanes i'm like
where was the smoking section
but the fact is that we don't do that
now if you lit up on an airplane people
would look at you like have you lost
your mind yes there's an eject button
they think
so catherine so could you give me an
example
of
a subsidy that we're not otherwise
privy to that amounts to the 600 billion
a year
yeah i can give you two types of
examples and this also speaks to the
economic costs so first of all you have
direct subsidies where for example um
oil and gas companies are paying
you know pennies on the dollar for their
land leases that they negotiated decades
ago and they're actually pulling from
the public good they're pulling coal and
gas and oil from publicly owned lands
and they're paying a fraction of
pittance of what that is actually worth
but then there's the indirect subsidies
and the way we set up our economic
system is we did not put a dollar sign
on externalities which is the fancy
economist word for things that we don't
price things outside our economic system
and so they didn't put a dollar sign on
all of the heat trapping gases we
produce yet those heat trapping gases
are producing very costly and certainly
valuable impacts on us every day just to
give you one example hurricane harvey
hurricane harvey
incurred over 120 billion dollars worth
of direct impacts the indirect impacts
extend for decades afterwards
it's estimated that 75
of those costs would not have occurred
if that hurricane had been supersized by
climate change so that's a single event
you're looking at over 80 billion
dollars from a single event that's a lot
of dollars carbon really is carrying a
cost and until we incorporate it into
our economic system we have a socialized
system which is kind of ironic for most
people because people think oh those
climate solutions are socialized no no
our current system is socialized because
we all of us as taxpayers and insurance
owners and homeowners and people who who
uh suffer the impacts of fossil fuel use
we are paying for the price and a few
companies are reaping the benefit right
and it started early on i guess because
we paid to build the roads that then the
cars that use gasoline drive on all
right so the people who made the cars
didn't build the roads to use their
product so that's uh this goes way back
if you're gonna add it up that way i
think but chuck let's get to some
cosmic queries okay let's see if we can
fit one in before the break all right
what do you have let's do it
this is
tyler
hanel and tyler says hello you wonderful
group of humans when discussing climate
change there is often this misconception
that simply because there have been
episodes of dramatic climate change in
earth's history that our current era of
predominantly human driven climate
change is less threatening than it
appears could you touch upon what
separates our current episode of climate
change from those that have occurred in
the past
and this is kevin the samoa yay
yeah
okay and and
i i don't know if tyler hannel sent that
through kevin the san manie but whatever
okay
all right
well tyler actually
hit the nail on the head because it's
been warmer before or it's just a
natural cycle is the number one sciency
sounding objection to the reality of
climate change number one because it
sounds so plausible right oh it's been
warmer before haven't you seen jurassic
park they're making a reboot of jurassic
park now so more people will see it
but when we look into the past and
paleoclimate scientists are the ones who
do this what we see from the past makes
us even more worried about what we're
seeing today
not less
let's take off a few of the ways that we
get more worried number one
we should be slowly gradually cooling
right now not warming according to
natural factors which include the sun
volcanoes and orbital cycles our planet
should be very very very slowly
heading into the next glacial maximum or
ice age instead we're getting warmer
faster and faster so number one is the
direction of the change is wrong number
two
we are warming faster than any time in
the history of human civilization on
this planet
and our whole civilization where we
build our cities how we allocate our
resources our water resources where we
grow our food it's all based on the
assumption of a stable climate and now
we're changing faster than any time we
humans have experienced and then as far
back as you can go in the paleoclimate
record tens of millions of years or more
we've never seen this much carbon going
into the atmosphere this quickly so we
are truly conducting an unprecedented
experiment with the only home we have
and the potential for some very nasty
surprises increases with every single
year that we don't turn this thing
around
damn katherine just bumming us all out
last time i'm gonna invite you on this
show
and now uh with that you can get a
recording of this to read to your
children before bedtime
just to make it clear the astronomical
cycles to which you refer yes they do
cycle but on way longer time scales than
what we have seen
so
yeah so it's not an escape
hat an escape route for those who are
trying to sound sciency in their
objections for sure
for sure chuck we're going to take a
quick break when we come back more with
catherine hale we'll see if she can have
something nice to say about our future
maybe kevin you got something nice to
say otherwise we're not coming back yes
yes yes fine okay
you heard it here this is star talk neil
degrasse tyson we'll be right back start
talk cosmic query because we're talking
about what any of us can do
about the climate crisis and anytime
that's the topic we need catherine hayjo
in the house
catherine how do we find you on social
media katherine it's pretty easy there's
not a lot of catherine hayhoes in the
world uh i'm on twitter and instagram
and facebook and linkedin and i'm trying
catherine with a cat with a k and i'm
trying out tick tock with the help of my
cat
oh cats will get you far in that one
yeah so hey ho h-a-y-h-o-e
yes so chuck you got another question
for sure
let's this is
okay
it is now susan tukey all right i'll
give you a c plus on that one you know
how it's supposed to be pronounced
you're getting a c plus c
e n t k u
t i
shouldn't yeah okay all right
so
bents
is uh how much do humans actually
contribute to the heating of the planet
besides or
uh in addition to natural causes
thank you in advance what's our
what's our culpability
yeah we humans are responsible for
more
than a hundred percent of the observed
warming
now people often say what do you mean
more than 100 that's not possible well
it is possible if according to natural
factors as we discussed right before the
break we should be getting cooler not
warmer so all of the observed warming is
human caused and then we are actually
offsetting a little bit of extra natural
cooling
oh wow so you have to
you have to subtract what we would have
been
from what we are and you find that what
we are is a hundred percent
plus
plus the difference for what we would
have been
yes
without it without it correct correct so
so so how does that translate to of all
the co2 in the air right now what
percent of that co2 are we so rather
than think about it in warming let's
think about it chemically yeah so before
the industrial revolution
co2 was at 280 parts per million in the
atmosphere and now people say 280 parts
per million sounds like nothing
well 280 parts per million of cyanide in
your glass would you drink it no you
wouldn't because it's very powerful and
carbon dioxide is a very powerful heat
trapping gas a little bit of it goes a
long way and in fact methane is an even
more powerful heat trapping gas than
carbon dioxide and it's been going up
even more it was about 800 parts per
billion before and now co2 is at over
120 parts per million and methane is at
over 1800 parts per billion so big right
so co2 you're saying we've increased it
by 25
yes
more than that
now now uh co2 fluctuates according to
the plant cycles the annual plant cycles
right
so is that number you gave me like the
average on the year and then we're
increment on that average yes so it goes
up and down with the northern hemisphere
it's sort of like the earth breathing
because plants take up co2 as they grow
and then they give off co2 as they die
back and so we see this amazing annual
cycle in co2 in the atmosphere which is
essentially the planet breathing
in and spring and out in northern
hemisphere fall but then we have the
long-term average that ticks steadily
upwards and if you just look at the peak
the peak is already over 120 but the
average is just approaching it
wow got it so we're basically
the
cigarettes of the planet
that's who yeah
so yeah yeah
like you know if you're just breathing
normally and you know you're you're
you're taking your lungs they're fine
when you all of a sudden you start
smoking and they're totally messed up so
if you think of the planet as the planet
breathing
all right so the lungs yeah okay human
kind is is the cigarettes to what the
planet should be
we're giving we're giving earth lung
cancer lung cancer
okay so that totally works chuck because
i use that in a slightly different
analogy because people say well how much
is too much and what's the magic number
where should we stop and i'm like
there's no magic number to cigarettes
but you know that is the sooner you stop
the better and people say well is it too
late and i say well we've already got
impaired lung capacity we've already got
some spots on our lungs so to speak as
if we've been smoking a pack of
cigarettes a day for years and even
decades but we don't have emphysema we
don't have lung cancer and we're not
dead yet so i'm going to add that to the
analogy because it totally works awesome
i love it there you go
you know that the problem is the people
who just like you know my uncle he
smoked for 30 years
he smoked until he was 92. he was
totally fine totally i mean he didn't
have fingertips but who cares
who needs those when you're 90.
well we have we have those people too
they're like it's freezing here where is
global warming now right right okay
all right so so
well globally references climate not
your days forecast weather forecast
right so so catherine
what solutions i mean you j you gave a
short
listing in the first segment on things
that are being done or on the frontier
of carbon capture uh could you just be a
little more specific about what what are
some of the things that happen because
when i think about it the carbon's in
the earth and we take it out and it's in
the atmosphere but it's been in the
earth for millions of years let's get it
back into the earth rather than in the
atmosphere and it sounds like a lot of
what you're describing is just that
exactly so carbon is the building block
of life
carbon is not essentially
evil or bad we need it we depend on it
but when you have too much of a good
thing
that can be dangerous and so you know if
you eat too much of something or if you
take too many veg
vitamins or especially if you take too
much medicine you can take too much of
something that's good for you and it
actually makes you sick and so that's
exactly what we've got here we've got
too much carbon in the atmosphere and we
want to put it back where carbon wants
to go if you could sort of personify
carbon carbon loves to go into
ecosystems because again we're all
carbon-based life forms and so it's not
just planting trees when we restore
coastal wetlands which protect us from
storm surge and also filter water they
store carbon when we protect our
peatlands they store carbon when you
regrow grasslands they store carbon when
you green low-income neighborhoods in
big urban cities it cools them down
cleans up their air and stores carbon
and carbon in the soil is amazing
fertilizer and so when farmers do really
simple things like planting a cover crop
and then the cover crop takes up carbon
as it grows you plow the cover crop back
into the ground before you plant your
regular crop and all of that lovely
carbon from those plants goes into the
ground where it enriches the next crop
so all of these are what we call
nature-based solutions working with
nature they're incredible ways to
help with our farming help with our
ecosystems invest in nature and
biodiversity and cleaning up our air and
cleaning up our water oh and they help
with climate change too they're like win
win win win and win solutions so have
you heard of this um
the scientists i read this in
smithsonian so i'm not well versed on it
um
that sounds like you are if you're
reading the smithsonian magazine well
i'm not well-versed but i read
smithsonian in scientific america and
this in five years right but i'm not
well-versed yes but i'm just i'm not a
scientist you know what i mean so it's
not like i'm reading a peer review study
or something okay go ahead go ahead
there there's this uh technology where
you're able to pull carbon from the
ocean so that the ocean can absorb more
carbon but then turn the carbon into
rock or limestone
do you know anything about that
yes so there's direct air and direct
water capture where you literally pull
the co2 directly out of the air the
atmosphere or out of the water and you
turn it into a product and they have
turned it into rock they have turned it
into baking soda and here's the really
good one
they have been able to pull carbon out
of the air and turn it into liquid fuel
uh oh that no no no that's a no i'm
saying that is awesome yes yes yes yes
because it's one thing to replace our
electricity sources with clean energy
with wind or solar or tidal or hydro or
others but liquid fuel is kind of the
holy grail because for example like with
an airplane you can fly short flights
with a battery so electric planes are
actually a reality today but you can't
fly really long flights with a battery
because the battery would weigh too much
you need liquid fuel so if you could
take the carbon out of the atmosphere if
you could turn it into liquid fuel and
then when you re-burn it what you're
doing is you're creating essentially
carbon neutral fuel you're neither
adding nor subtracting to the amount of
carbon in the atmosphere right because
it came from the atmosphere okay so that
would if if everybody did that that
would peg us at the current levels so
we'd have to get used to the storms and
things we have now but it won't get
worse necessary correct
okay
okay and so so so
that liquid fuel are you saying you can
make that coming out of the ocean and
out of the air i'm only familiar with
the way they make it coming out of the
air but here's the problem like you
might say well why aren't they doing it
everywhere
one answer
it's a lot more expensive than natural
gas because we live in this artificially
subsidized economy where exactly fossil
fuels are cheap and clean energy new
clean energy technology is not okay so i
got to get got to get into the chemistry
of this so if i have co2 in the
atmosphere and you want to pull it out
and make fuel which has chemical energy
you have to put energy into that
molecule to make it happen where are you
getting that energy well you exactly put
your finger on it neil you have to get
that energy from clean sources otherwise
you could be creating a low carbon fuel
but you're not creating a
no carbon yeah and you could you could
essentially add to the problem depending
on the amount of energy you need to make
the fuel
yeah it's like bring that gallon of gas
over here so i can make a carbon neutral
right
burn down this forest so we can actually
fly a plane
well that's what they did with ethanol
so the the old-fashioned way to take um
carbon out of the atmosphere and turn it
into fuel is through this amazing
technology called photosynthesis
where
you grow things and the as they grow
they take the carbon out like corn and
then you turn those things you grew into
fuel well in brazil they have sugar cane
that they've been doing this with for a
long time and sugar cane is a very high
sugar content
so in some cases you do get a lower
carbon product from from biofuels but
for ethanol in the united states they've
done study after study and i actually
just read a new one last week showing
that ethanol was not a lower carbon fuel
than fossil fuels because so much energy
had to go into actually producing the
fuel right
sam what do you think of the
first of all let me forget what do you
think of it is it true
what we see in these
seemingly green washing television
commercials about all this algae that's
being grown
and turned into biofuel
well algae is really cool because it you
know you this algae pulls co2 out of the
atmosphere and then you've got this
algae that you could turn into fuel and
the technology exists to turn it into
liquid fuel in fact um back in the day
they had some experiments where they
just set up these giant bags
of blue green algae sort of in the
parking lot beside a coal fire power
plant and they pump the co2 from the
coal fire power plant directly into the
bag so they weren't even taking it from
the atmosphere to create algae growth
and they were doing that as an
experiment it wasn't operational just to
show that you could do it
but here's the thing a lot of the big
oil and gas companies they are investing
in new technology like algae like
biofuels like carbon capture
but the amount that they talk about it
doesn't match what they're actually
doing and in fact earlier this year
there was a peer-reviewed scientific
study chuck speaking of the peer
reviewed literature
that formally found that many of the big
oil and gas companies are guilty of
greenwashing and that they claim to be
doing a lot more than they are actually
doing green washing man i love that term
interesting well chuck this is a cosmic
query so let's see if we can slip one in
before we end up let's do it here we go
this is uh alex reynoso
hello uh
alejandro reynoso from monterey mexico
here
okay
chuck does three accents only three
accents the rest we don't know what he's
talking about
okay
like i said
this is alejandro
i just said he does the accent i just
say he does this does the language
that's a whole other thing what are you
talking about here here's what he says i
believe the problem with the problem
with climate change is how we produce
and how much we produce that goes to
waste
specifically
i also think the climate change deniers
don't believe in it because they don't
want to make any change on their way of
life how can we shift the bias and
actually get something done so the i
mean the bias against changing your
lifestyle and of course changing your
lifestyle means either consuming less
or
consuming products that we don't throw
away
see i'm i'm with i'm with the questioner
on that only because like i said
you want me to do what you want me to go
out of my way you want me to spend more
on this you want me to do
i just want to do what i keep doing so i
think that the richest future person
is going to be the person that does an
exact substitute for what we're doing
now and that's all green technologies
and then i don't have to change my ways
if i'm liberal or conservative
i agree what do you say so
so much of the messaging around climate
action comes originally from the
environmental community which sort of
has an ethos of sacrifice
yes it does very perfectly worded
perfectly worded and and if you're not
sacrificing with us you are harming
somebody else right you eat babies
if you're not doing what we do
[Laughter]
you don't love anyone
no chuck it isn't eating babies it's
running over the babies in your suv
right right when you're here you go and
you'll avoid the baby seal right right
right
so no you're totally right and so that
appeals to a certain small percentage of
people who most of whom would call
themselves environmentalists but as you
just said chuck and as you just said
neil it doesn't appeal to most people
and so the messaging not in america
because america freedom i don't want you
telling me what to do
and a lot of people will even say that
like i don't want you telling me how to
set my thermostat i even have a story in
my book about that who a man said in
text that said you know what everything
you said makes sense but i don't want
the government telling me how to set my
thermostat and i said you're right i
don't want the government telling me
that either and so that's why it's so
important to talk about real solutions
real solutions like number one
waste is a problem especially
inefficiency we waste half no we waste
68 of the energy we produce we waste
half the food we produce so waste not
want not is a huge time saver money
saver and carbon saver then transition
into clean energy so when we flip the
switch the light goes on but it's
powered by clean energy no matter who
you are no matter where you live um the
head of google's and it's the same and
it's the same damn light switch right
it's not some other configuration
contraption yeah the head of google said
i want everybody everybody who does a
google search to be powered by clean
energy when they do that search whether
they want to or not
that's what we need
right
right and when it comes to the food
wasting uh i just think that uh
everybody
in america and on earth
needs to spend just a month living with
a black grandmother
and you will not waste any food because
you will burn some toast and you will go
to throw that toast but boy what are you
doing that's a perfectly good toast
you're trying to throw that away
you better scrape that toast and put
some butter on it boy you know okay time
to take a break well i was just gonna
say
i grew up with the ukrainian grandmother
same thing
exact same thing okay
now here's a real test katherine all
right a little bit of mold on a roll
okay grandma does she say now you know
that's dangerous you can't eat that or
does she say you better cut that mold
off that roll and eat that roll and eat
the rest of the mold okay
people start complaining about their
grandmother it's time to take a break so
uh we're gonna come back cosmic queries
what we can do about the climate crisis
uh third segment coming right up
we're back third and final segment star
talk
what we can do about the climate crisis
catherine hey-ho in the house
catherine you are uniquely
effective at
getting people to hear what you're
saying and want to do what you say
so many other climate folks are they're
there to scold you rather than
bring you along
with what they have in mind
and so we need more of you right one of
you is not enough
do you think or or
short of cloning you what what other
what should people do who who have your
knowledge base do they
should they be more active on twitter
should they
teach classes on masterclass what what
should what do you expect of us well for
a long time in my twitter bio i had
first in line for cloning but then i
started to get some really weird emails
so i took it out and i wrote a book
instead
okay
now now i'm more interested in the
emails
oh believe me chuck i have a whole
folder
okay okay
um and the book is basically about how
every single one of us can do this no
matter who we are because every one of
us has a voice
but each one of us is unique so we all
come from a different background we have
different life experiences we have
different priorities and interests and
values and abilities and talents
and so who we are is the perfect person
to have that conversation with whatever
groups or organizations we're part of
where we work or where we go to school
or we might be somebody who's a skier or
we're talking with the other moms at the
playground or we're walking our dogs
together we're playing ultimate frisbee
together we're going to church everybody
plugs into their niche exactly with your
wisdom and they know how to communicate
with their own people because the social
science shows that us scientists we are
the second most trusted messengers on
climate change
the first most trusted messengers are
people you know a friend
mm-hmm
[Music]
okay
all right chuck let's let's get some
more cosmic queries
here we go this is all right
uh q-tone who says uh hey it's hunter
here um
uh
we are able to feed 70 billion animals
each year so humans can have meat to eat
on the table but we're unable to feed
the millions of starving humans on our
own planet what is being done about this
and how will factory farming evolve to
combat
this challenge as well as the challenge
of climate change
there's a lot to unpack in that question
i i know and in fact let me just lead
off by saying as i understand it unlike
the predictions of thomas malthus where
he said population is going to outstrip
food supply and we will
starve in mass numbers he didn't know
what role science would play in the
production of food so as i understand it
catherine correct me if i'm wrong there
is no shortage of food in the world
there's plenty of food and we can have
food and even up to 10 billion people
but it's the distribution networks of
food
and that is the problem right and so i
don't know that
climate change issues or food production
issues can actually solve that problem
it's a political problem isn't it well
that's exactly it we waste in in
high-income countries we waste 50 of the
food that we produce just buy too much
on our plates throw it out rotting in
the back of the fridge ugly fruit you
know food just passed its deadline ugly
fruit yeah there's literally they take
it off the grocery shelf if it's too
ugly i thought this this is farm
cooperative that sells ugly fruit i
think it's called something like that
and you go there it's got some gnarly
tomatoes you know and
and it's weird how we have a food
aesthetic that has nothing to do with
its nutritional value that's sad
actually it's very sad but what's even
sadder is in low-income countries
they're also wasting about half their
food too but for a completely different
reason because they don't have the
refrigeration in the supply chain to get
it to market and to distribute it and to
keep it from going back so spoiled
preserving the spoils yeah and then then
you have the challenge that industrial
agriculture especially beef and to a
lesser extent other animal agriculture
is responsible for about 14 percent of
our heat trapping gas emissions too so
there's this whole ball of wax ton pack
where we need to figure out how to stop
wasting food how to provide food to
people who need it and how to
shift our agricultural system to one
that is truly sustainable that provides
for our needs and replenishes the needs
of the planet as well you know that
reminds me of i saw a comedian joke
about this i mean it's a very serious
topic but the
the joke made it even more serious he
was saying you know
if he had a pen pal from some
other nobody has pen pals anymore but a
pen pal from some nation that is
developing and food is a scarce resource
and you're telling each other about each
other's cultures and so what did you do
last week oh we had
we we celebrated what we call
thanksgiving here in the united states
well what do you do oh we eat as much as
we possibly can until we
on the brink of throwing up we have to
unbuckle our belt a few notches and then
we just roll onto the couch until we
digest it and then we go back for more
what did you do on your holiday i mean
the stark contrast of our access to food
and plus i don't know any other country
that has so many fitness centers to burn
off the excess food that we ended up
eating never mind the food that we ended
up throwing away
so true now for some reason i am hungry
okay
give me another one okay oh sorry you
have want to say catherine even here
though we have food deserts right we
have places where people live in poverty
where they don't have access to grocery
stores that sell healthy foods it's all
pre-packaged expensive foods so food is
a problem really everywhere
and it's not because of a food shortage
in the world right it's a it's a whole
other problem
okay chuck what else you have here we go
this is uh bill
uh wesley and bill wisely says with the
consuming rush to electrification aren't
we at risk of running out of electricity
do we need
distributed neighborhood micro nuclear
power plants plus large parts of the
world uh doesn't have a sufficient
electrical distribution how will those
parts join the rush to electrification
i like that many new nuclear plants
so so catherine let me let me co-op that
question and ask you what's the future
of nuclear power if there's no carbon
footprint well that that is in my book
as well um
as they say nuclear fusion is always 30
years away
it's been 30 years away 30 years ago and
it still is today so in the future maybe
in our grandchildren's time nuclear
fusion could supply a lot of our
electricity but not necessarily our
other energy sources so even that holy
grail so to speak is not a fix-all it's
not a silver bullet for everything
in the meantime now we have old school
nuclear technology which is so expensive
that the only plant they tried to build
in the u.s in the last 30 years was in
the carolinas the bil the price went so
far over budget that they essentially
dug a hole in the ground and filled it
back in for nine billion dollars
but all is not lost because idaho
national labs in partnership with one of
bill gates startups they are developing
what what bill referred to as the mini
modular nuclear reactors where you can
literally put one on the back of a truck
so you don't have to build it in situ
you build them as a module and then you
you transport as many as you need and
put them together and they're trying
that out for the first time in utah
right now so it's like legos exactly
nuclear legos
and if you cite them somewhere where
there are no earthquakes tsunamis or
other natural disaster risks
then they are relatively safe and
relatively affordable although solar is
still cheaper so for some places under
some circumstances there could be the
role for that but then you still have
the nuclear waste disposal issue
we don't need a silver bullet we need
silver buckshot we need solutions that
work for everyone and you know to
generate all the electricity for the
whole united states here today using
only solar energy we would need about a
hundred by a hundred square mile area in
west texas
and i mean what is that six cotton farms
there you go
so so
we don't need a lot of land area and
like i said we're very inefficient if we
would just increase our efficiency
we could cut our carbon emissions and
our energy use in half and then there's
the 700 million people who don't have
access to electricity most of whom live
in sub-saharan africa well they don't
have a lot of coal or gas or oil there
but they have a lot of sun and a lot of
wind
and during the pandemic in 2020 90 of
new energy installed around the world
much of that in those places that don't
have access to electricity was clean
energy yeah and by the way uh it appears
that uh they're poised to
accelerate and to do better with clean
energy because they are building from
scratch
so they don't have to modernize a grid
or retrofit anything they just build
from the bottom up and you know
it's like the city of dubai uh where
they
see basically built in the last couple
of decades almost everything you see
there and it looks like a city in the
future whereas all other cities have to
sort of combine stuff that's a century
old where
science and technology and architecture
is advanced crazy stuff all right chuck
give me another one i've got more
questions coming before you katherine
here we go it's on right now
this is why
this is wide cost
she's coming for you or he's coming for
you uh or they're coming from you he's
uh this person says while i personally
don't necessarily agree
with your views on this matter
i wonder how you would respond to the
late mathematical physicist freeman
dyson who acknowledged humans effect on
the climate but
questioned if this effect was
necessarily bad and if it was the most
important immediate concern for the
majority of the world's people
a view promoted by the eco-modernist
movement isn't progress for the
developing nations more important than
their effect on the global climate
um so that's okay so what i got to lead
off i got to say something about freeman
dyson because i knew him i was at
princeton while he was there he died a
few years ago a brilliant physicist
second world war worked for the uk
um he's british physicist but was at the
institute for advanced study in
princeton while i was at princeton
university we had lunch every tuesday
there's a big group of us
and so brilliant guy
not a climate scientist
that's all i have to say
that's all i have to say so if you want
to cherry pick
the random comments
of people no matter their education
level that conflict with those of the
emerging consensus
of
data and results of climate scientists
then you are revealing
your own bias in this you are you you
have your bias and you're looking for
things to fulfill it and if you have to
leave the chorale
and find the wanderers who agree with
you this is not how we come to learn and
understand how the universe actually
works all right neil i'ma just say this
i don't know if i agree with you i had
that's the freeman dyson side now let me
hand this my hand off to the catholics i
got my lasik surgery done by a
proctologist
that's exactly where i was going chuck
you know somebody could be a great
cardiologist wait is that because he
mistook your ass to your face
you you made me you made me do
oh my god that was good catherine okay
we have to answer the question
[Laughter]
oh chuck you rolled out the red carpet
on that one
oh my god
this is what happens when i don't take a
nap
okay
so kevin so go so go for it
i think that the strongest question
there we have a developing country that
is on the brink of of of of reaping the
fruits and benefits
that developed countries have reaped
using the inexpensive
prospect of oil which is just coming
right out of the ground and it's
transportable it's got has high energy
density and all of a sudden the western
world is saying you can't do this
because it's bad for the environment
when we did what was bad for the
environment for 150 years so
why is that even fair
and who are we to say what they should
or shouldn't do that is a straw man
argument i hear frequently and as your
listeners probably know a straw man
argument is where you say something that
isn't true and then you ask somebody to
explain why it's true
so no one is telling developing
countries what they can or can't do the
paris agreements contributions are
entirely voluntary
every country determines their own
contribution to the paris agreement
nobody else tells them what it is that's
number one nobody's telling them what to
do and number two is this
one of the biggest reasons why
low-income countries are low-income is
because they do not have massive fossil
fuel resources and the few countries
that do like nigeria venezuela brazil
those resources are used to enrich
a very few elite and the multinational
corporations and those riches do not
trickle down to the average person so
when we say oh those developing
countries should be using fossil fuels
like we did what we are saying is oh
they should be using model t fords right
now and party line telephones they
shouldn't be using the technology we
have today because they have to do in
the same order we did and oh by the way
they have to buy it all from us because
they don't have it
it is
the most colonialistic and patronizing
perspective that you could possibly
imagine let them pick how they want to
do it because you know what the 3.5
billion poorest people in the world so
far have produced seven percent of
emissions so if they want to go ahead
and burn some fossil fuels on their way
to a clean energy future they've got a
long way to go before they catch up with
the united states of america that is
responsible for almost 30 percent of
cumulative carbon emissions
yeah ryan
mike dropped mike
yeah
mike in addition to that by the way um
the geopolitically this is how strong
men and dictators are made
when you because they don't care they
don't need to take care of their people
all they need to do is take the
commodity and sell it to somebody like
us
in order to maintain power and to uh
sustain a system of oppression
chuck is running for office
okay
no
so guys we got to end the show so
chuck always good to have you as you
know catherine do you have any final
words for us that might give us some
hope for the future yes i would love to
end with some words from a fellow
climate scientist who is in ukraine
right now svetlana krakowska she's an
ipcc author and what she said when they
were just releasing the latest ipcc
report the latest door stop of doom
showing all the terrible things that are
happening to this world because of
climate change this is what she said she
said climate change and the war on
ukraine have the same roots fossil fuels
but she went on she said just as we will
not surrender we must not surrender to
building a climate resilient future as
well because all of us are at risk
there you go
powerful stuff
there it is catherine you know we're
going gonna have you back this was your
third visit and we're not done with you
and i'm delighted that you you that you
you tolerate both me and chuck in this
this is because this that takes a little
bit
i
i enjoy neil that takes its own
special set of resiliency
resilience there you go there you go
catherine we're all better citizens
because of you on this earth thank you
for sharing your time with star talk
this has been star talk cosmic queries
becoming a better
citizen to fight the climate crisis neil
degrasse tyson here as always keep
looking up
[Music]
you